SPEAKER 1: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a plethora of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance
to catch "Building Serverless
Applications with
Google Cloud Functions,"
stay tuned, because
here is the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a fancy new phrase
in the computing world known
as "serverless applications,"
which might be just
a little misleading.
SPEAKER 2: See, serverless
doesn't mean not using servers.
But instead it means that
you don't need to think about
deployment, provisioning,
or managing of the servers;
that you're working in a
pay-for-what-you-use model,
where you deploy
functions, not apps;
and you're working in an
event-based or event-oriented
model.
SPEAKER 1: To understand
why this is a helpful idea,
let's do a recap.
SPEAKER 2: In a typical
cloud computing application,
you have to set up and provision
some VMs, which handle traffic.
The number of VMs
you need is typically
a function of traffic volume.
And in order to respond
to requests efficiently,
you typically have
to over-provision.
This leads to wasted
money, since you're only
using those resources
in spiky scenarios.
Now recently,
containers were added
to the concept of
cloud computing, which
allow you to deploy a
container on a VM, which
can handle traffic by itself.
The difference here is
that as traffic rises,
you can allocate a new
container on the same VM rather
than a whole new VM itself.
SPEAKER 1: However, you end
up back in the same problem
if you end up with
[? modulus ?] overhead
between the number of
containers and the number of VMs
you have allocated.
Serverless is another way to
tackle this problem, where
you break down your
application into the smallest
functions possible.
You then deploy each
function and give it
the ability to handle capacity.
Then let some
other system handle
provisioning and allocation
in order to reduce
over-provisioning costs.
This is exactly the service
that Google Cloud Functions
provides.
It's a serverless environment
to build and connect services
through code, which
means that you don't
need to think about servers.
You only pay for what you use.
And it's all event-oriented.
SPEAKER 2: Here is
a small example.
Internal and external services
can emit events, like changes
to a cloud storage bucket.
And cloud functions
you've defined
will respond to
those events, which
can write back to the
cloud or call other APIs.
Now, developing a cloud function
is really straightforward.
Simply use your existing
knowledge of Node.js
and Express frameworks,
deploy your HTTP or background
functions, and
you're ready to go.
But the best part about all
this is that Cloud Functions
come built in with
Firebase and Stackdriver
support, which means
that you get access
to things like analytics,
database access, authentication
events, logging, monitoring,
and even an emulator,
so you can develop
and test locally
rather than in production.
SPEAKER 1: Check
out the recording
of Jason's full session
to learn more details
and see some great demos
for moving your existing
applications to
Google Cloud Platform.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Next
World Tour, coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]